invité de ce journal milos forman merci
d'être avec nous dans un instant vous
avez parlé de votre film valmont qui
sort sur les écrans français avec marie
claire gauthier
auparavant juste une question sur la
tchécoslovaquie que vous avez quitté en
1968 quand vous voyez le le rôle que
tient aujourd'hui vaclav havel dans le
mouvement dans ce qui se passe là bas
c'est d'ailleurs votre ami vous avez été
en classe avec lui je crois à l'âge de
14 ans que vous ne regrettez pas d'être
aussi loin aujourd'hui de la
tchécoslovaquie
on peut pas sauter 20 ans de la
séparation non écoute est ce la réalité
je suis j'ai parlé avec lui à peu près
trois mois
eh ben il ne faut pas oublier une chose
ce sont des artistes c'est pascal
ravenne aujourd'hui première place là
bas parce que ils peuvent s'exprimer ou
puff articuler les sentiments des gens
mais ce ne sont pas des politiciens sont
très vulnérables à ce point comme
politicien
merci on regarde tout de suite un
extrait de votre film vous retrouvez
ensuite avec marie claire gauthier
le nombre de filles
advanced track
nous sommes à deux bons soirs amadeus
c'était un visage de mozart va lancer un
regard sur les liaisons alors pourquoi
avalement pourquoi pas cécile ou madame
de merteuil non parce que bon c'est un
caractère j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
moi-même je n'ai jamais réussi
alors finalement il est plutôt gentil
dans votre dans votre film a beaucoup
pas pourquoi le gisement d'appeler les
lettres qu'il écrit soi-même pour
impressionner madame de merter non je
sue circulent avec des côtés très très
différents et qu'est ce que vous vous
avez voulu séduire le spectateur avec qu
avec la la perversité ou avec au
contraire l'innocentent dans tous les
départs ce que je crois que ceux ci ont
vraiment que ou jeu de comprendre ou de
s'amuser avec la décadence ou perversité
il faut aussi montrer innocence
parce qu'avec la comme comparaison c'est
l'âme ou l'autre ce qu'on compliments et
vu la scène la séduction de l'histoire
qu'avez vous l'avez lu bon comme tout le
monde quand vous étiez adolescent raison
différemment quant à 19 ans on vit cette
vivre avec les yeux de chimène et c'est
cette séduction aujourd'hui pour l'homme
mûr enfin pour le monsieur qui a fait le
film c'est la même à écouter ce sont des
et de questions on n'a pas vraiment de
réponse on ne cherche toujours c'est
pourquoi on fait d'être chrétien parce
que on ne trouve pas des réponses aux
questions de base non c'est un film que
vous avez tourné
bon c'est l'origine et françaises
scénario jean claude carrière français
une production qui est française tous
péri vous l'avez tournée en france et en
anglais oui ah bah écoutez je peux je
peux essayer ou appartements forme aux
français avez vous parlé très bien non
pas pour faire un grièvement
ça c'est applaudir de me demander de
prendre encore en langue une langue
savez il ya des chefs internationaux qui
s'exprime à partir du moment où il
fallut musique qui s'expriment très très
bien avec les mollahs est ce que ça
vient de la distribution de comédiens
est-ce que vous avez trouver plus
facilement les acteurs que vous
cherchiez soit aux états unis soit en
grande bretagne ah non ça se passe je
suis sûr qu'il ya tellement de très bons
acteurs ici et ici en france non mais
parce que fumeur l'indre et alors on a
fait la distribution à los angeles à new
york et à londres
et on se concentre est on trouve des
gens qui correspond vraiment à l'âge qui
est décrit dans le livre parce que dans
le livre se situe à 15 ans tour loi 22
ans dans le monde bertincourt 30
alors bon malraux donne une définition
2d des liaisons que vous connaissez
enfin c'est
veut coucher avec intel qui veut pas
coucher etc alors c'est un peu le
problème des poupées russes en face et
la séduction en poupées russes
est ce que est ce que vous vous êtes
sensible à ça est ce que c'est c'est un
des points qui vous a touché dans dans
l'histoire naturellement oui parce que
ce sont des mystères qui nous excite le
plus non parce que l'amour d'une côté
tellement dedans peut étendre fabuler de
l'autre côté c'est vraiment un trio
thèse c'est la guerre si on tombe
amoureux avec un bon alors on essaie de
posséder cette personne on veut que
cette personne est toujours avec vous et
si on n'avait pas la guerre comment vous
allez faire mais deus vous avez fait
valmont vous avez une préférence
maintenant oui vraiment mais voilà merci
milos forman il me reste le temps de
vous souhaiter knicks